I was raised to think that there was I
couldn't do anything don't don't get
your hopes up never occurred to me that
anything I was doing ever could ever
make anybody uncomfortable
I could see it offending someone yeah
which great there was nothing else in
the world that I could possibly do there
was nothing else I could do
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
in your journey today we're gonna learn
from comedian and writer Larry David and
my take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
do you know why you wanted to be a
comedian yeah because I had no there was
nothing else in the world that I could
possibly do there was nothing else I
could do uh yeah I had nothing and it
seemed like I was funny so why not try
and use this particular skill that I had
to make a living because there was
nothing else that I could do I was
raised to think that there was I
couldn't do anything don't don't get
your hopes up okay I remember one day I
remember one time I was asked in front
of my mother
you know what what I might want to be I
said yeah I really like sports maybe I
could be a sports announcer she goes
you're not special you're not gonna be a
sports you know she wanted me to be a
mailman really that was her dream yes
she wanted me to take the civil service
test and become a mailman because you
know they did you get the security and
you always have a paycheck and a pension
so being that being a comedian didn't
occur to me then I got out of college
and my friend's wife kept saying you
know you're funny why aren't you doing
stand-up comedy because I was
floundering I went to watch a night of
comedy as I'm watching it I'm going
Jesus I think you know what I think I
couldn't do this and in the middle of
the show I walk up to Budd Friedman
who's the manager of the club the owner
of the club and I say I'd like to go on
yeah like how insane is that I want to
go on I have nothing okay
I've never been on a stage I want to go
on thank God
he said who are you no of course not you
can't go on you got a audition I know
okay so then I wrote some material and I
started trying to do it before I did
Seinfeld I was very bleak I would wake
up in the morning and my first thought
in my head was oh no you know oh I got
to go through this now what day another
day yeah but one Seinfeld started all
those thoughts were or gosh I feel did
what for you it gave you it gave me a
reason to I don't know it it focused me
on something but success and give you
confidence I guess yeah I don't know you
know when you're working hard your focus
you just you just do it you don't really
think about it you work on Seinfeld for
what it was eight ten years I worked on
it for a seventh season okay it's one of
the most successful and now revered
television shows ever
and yet you were writer on it I you
appeared once in a while but you you
weren't a performer do you have some
were you feeling supported is it as no
no not not in the slightest first of all
there was no way that I could have that
I could have done the amount of writing
that was required and also performed on
the show would have been impossible and
it never even occurred to me first then
Jason Alexander is you you've have you
stand out right and he's so amazing and
so incredible and so funny iiiii no no I
no way I'm gonna be as good as he is so
I was quite content to just be behind
the scenes and and writing and I didn't
know really that I had any talent in
that area any
I never thought of myself as an actor I
took an acting class I didn't like it
you know I didn't like waiting for the
other person through talking you know
III have to have to wait to say my line
what kind of [ __ ] is that you know I
I want to talk when I want to talk so
there was something about it that I
didn't I didn't like so I had no desire
to do it
mm-hmm and the writing was was fun some
of the best times in my life were
working on those scripts and then you
know working with Jerry in the room we
had just a fantastic time doing it where
with all behind that now classic Larry
David as a stand-up comedian moment of
walking onstage saying I don't think so
and walking off the level of confidence
behind that you may not even be aware of
because what you're saying is you people
it's not just that you're not up to this
so I'm leaving I'm gonna be invited back
the fact that I'm not going to perform
right now is not going to affect
anything right well that's a level of
confidence I don't think you were aware
of yeah it was uh you know I think think
because they got a kick out of my
shenanigans I think they did so and when
that happens you can't oh that gave me
yeah because that in Bolden Bay right
and you'd lean into it a little bit yeah
by the way I love the word I love using
the word in bold and so make sure to put
that into part of the job is to go too
far enough to push the boundaries to
make people uncomfortable to make people
laugh but also to make them squirm a
little bit
okay you know what I never knew about
the squirrel squirming stuff yeah so
that you know we do the show and it's in
and it's on the air and and all of a
sudden people start coming up to me I
have to leave the room I couldn't watch
that scene I go really you know and then
I kept hearing it over and over again
people
closing their eyes in this one no no not
just just in general that yes they were
squirming they would cover up or you
know they couldn't look at it because I
was making them so uncomfortable it
never occurred to me that anything I was
doing ever could ever make anybody
uncomfortable
I could see it offending someone yeah
which great you know that's the point
yeah no does that mean that's the point
well as SJ Pearlman said the office of
humor is to offend so I didn't I don't I
don't mind that when have you ever
offended when if you felt sort of out
there of this one really this one push
that push the outer limits well the
survivor episode you should admit you
should explain a little bit well there's
a show on CBS called the survivor a
reality show and then there are
Holocaust survivors
and one day
I heard survivor and then I thought
survivor and I went holy Sh and you know
my head exploded don't forget how funny
that could be and I thought I have got
to write this and film it as fast as I
possibly can because somebody's gonna
come up with this idea it's just so
obvious survivor survivor I've done this
you know one of the things I've heard is
that is that a lot of curb is is
improvised much more so than Seinfeld so
I'm curious in a scene like that how how
does it work when you're writing so you
just you write Larry rants about
something I mean most of the time yeah
it's an outline Seinfeld was a script
and all the dialogue was written right
everybody had their lines
that's scene you just saw there were no
lines Cheryl knows that she knows what
happened she sees that they toilet
papered the house because I didn't give
them candy and we just go and that's
that's what happens I mean that's and
that's it and the same thing in the
scene the interaction with the with the
cops this the whole riff on baldness
that's just something you just the cops
are there
I'm trying yeah I'm upset about what
happened I want satisfaction and that's
pretty much the scene writing this way
is that easier then then when you were
doing Seinfeld with everything scripted
or is it harder because it puts more
pressure on getting everything right
it's it's easier it's easier because
first of all the reason I knew I was
that I wanted to do this was because on
Seinfeld there were scenes where I would
go
oh the this the scene is so setup that
it kind of writes itself
there's nothing to write really all I
have to do is just say what people are
gonna say but I know what they're going
say because it's so simple because of
the way the scene is constructed so here
I just thought well why even memorize
I'm not even an actor anyway you know
we'll get to that I'm not an actor I
don't want to memorize stuff and and
wait for the other person to stop
talking before I want to talk I've got a
lot to say and I want to interject you
know so and also I remember I took an
improv class years ago many years ago
and I could remember almost every
compliment I've ever had in my life
and I remember at that at that improv
class I remember the the teacher said to
me you're very good at this you know and
and like that kind of stuck in my head
I'm very good at improvising you know
very good at it and so and so I thought
well let's let's I'll just write the
outline and we'll improvise and see what
happens when psycho who made the
decision to end it well I left two years
before it was over yeah and then Jerry
went on for the last two years and then
he decided even though it was doing oh
yeah yeah cuz he just was working so
hard
yeah well that it would be nine years
for him or seven years from me
was it hard to leave um I I think I was
ready I just thought like seven years
was a long time to be doing that and and
also you know after you do these shows
for a while the bar is so high that it's
almost intimidating to think how am I
gonna do another twenty two shows it's
it seems impossible you know so I would
go through that same thing every year
and then finally I thought that one of
the guys the money Python told me he
said we didn't think we could be that
good every year oh yeah oh that we could
beat that bunny yeah it's it's um you're
running against your son Yeah right
you're in competition against your
previous seasons and what did you think
you were gonna do
I didn't didn't really know but okay
this is actually a question from my
sister Annabelle and she's actually
watching so what she's watching online
online yes yeah I see you can't breathe
in this world cannot breathe it's all
online yeah yeah and anyway so I was
wondering if you could respond and look
at the camera and say Annabelle cuz it's
to her if that would be all right I mean
it's just rather than looking at me
let's let's pretend this is Larry David
from the show that's right just what I
was going to suggest exactly tell your
sister she could have come okay she's in
California goddamn question what's your
question Annabelle allow play all right
well she's in California in schools oh
oh that's why she's there it's okay I'm
sorry I know what are you studying
she is I she's studying um
she's studying public relations and in
film at USC fascinating and Annabelle
what is your question her question if
you could look at the camera I
[Laughter]
the balls on this guy Jesus Christ okay
do you have any other direction what
else do you want me to do should I stand
uh if you want I mean I said okay but
really her question night you've
answered part of it but I hate to
brother I'm gonna strangle this guy I
can't even look at him I ask the
questions I have to look at you wait
first the funniest part is when you sit
up I was actually gonna say gong because
of the Howard Stern Show setup and you
were doing that anyway I thought that
would have been funny but maybe you'd
hate maybe you would have hated me more
but anyway her question is what made you
want to make a satirical show about your
life I mean obviously you said why why I
wanted up happening but what actually
made you personally want to do it do
what Curb Your Enthusiasm well we did
this special like we talked about and
people seem to like it so why not but
was there a feeling of is that okay
I'll tell you what why don't you call me
at the office we'll go out to lunch and
then you know I'll tell you anything you
want we got two more fine I'm just
wondering when you're coming up with
ideas do you sort of parse it as a
[Applause]
New Yorker he's in New York yeah you if
you've gone to the Vanity Fair thing
nothing like this so you come up with an
idea
do you and give the label it as
something you might use in a stand-up
box or you sort of then think it might
be a part of the show sorry
when you come up with an idea just
immediately scream or more
I have to I have to say you're a bit of
a low talker did you hear any of that
yeah all right all right let's defeat
the question come on it's essentially
when you come up with an idea do you
immediately decide whether it's
something in the Sun apart or whether
it's something you'd put in the show
when you come up with the idea or
marinates and then you terminal thanks
Ron just say no yeah a little bit
what was it be nice this is one of my
god I'm gonna yeah you're gonna get a
good answer how did I go from being
Larry David's radical narcissist
- Larry David radical environmentalist
let me give you some background I grew
up in Brooklyn of all the wonders and
pleasures that exist in nature none of
them could be found in Brooklyn the only
grass I ever saw was on the divider of
the Belt Parkway there were no flowers
just artificial ones every apartment had
artificial flowers people took great
pride in their artificial flowers and
fruit let's not leave out the fruit
anything fake we love good fake things
the greatest compliment you could give
somebody was to mistakenly pick up a
piece of their artificial fruit and take
a bite out of it that made their day but
I couldn't smell a real flower anyway I
was born with the ability to only smell
disgusting things I never smell anything
pleasant ever you can shove a lilac up
my nose and I once melody but urine and
Bo I can smell from three blocks away
and Brooklyn was not wanting four
disgusting odors bus fumes garbage
cigarette smoke everybody in Brooklyn
smoked even nine-year-olds the whole
borough was hacking and coughing and
spitting it was phlegm everywhere it was
flying it from every direction out of
windows cars anyway you walked now to
keep ducking so you wouldn't get hit it
was like a shooting gallery
and of course needless to say there were
no animals in my life my mother hated
animals all of them if she had a way she
would kill every living animal on the
planet she looked at extinction is a
good thing when an animal was put on the
endangered species list she went out and
got drunk one of all time you need some
what good are they doing there was
nothing in nature we appreciate it
sunsets were mocked
[Music]
who moon in particular held no
fascination for anyone I don't think I
ever heard anyone even used it in a
sentence anyway whatever harm has been
done to the environment and I know
there's been a lot it's never really
affected me personally in any way that
is until a few months ago the first
thing that happened was I noticed
something on my face and it turned out
to be a benign skin cancer which was
caused by ozone depletion on me
all right you know was benign of course
when people noticed the bandage and
asked me what happened and I told him it
was cancer I played it up a bit the
first time anyone's felt sorry for me
since they published my income eight
years ago
when you have money the only way you can
get any sympathy at all is to say I've
cancer you can lose a limb no one would
care only one they know you're gonna die
you get anyone feeling sorry for you and
even then some people don't serve them
right the rich prick that's what I am
now rich prick trickle always falls the
word rich and correct you're a prick
just the way schmuck always follows the
word poor
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Todd Thomas
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson are you going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leave
it in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Helen from
stronghold media Helen thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and doing that review on your
website I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
read thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
you were a sort of a Comics comic that
the people read the comics like me well
no it's like being a writers writer yeah
the audience did not like me I can tell
you that they did not like me I would be
doing it I would hear that the vile
vicious comments that it's unbelievable
the disrespect it was it was startling
to see what people would do with a
couple of drinks in them what they would
call out what they would say and I'm a
sensitive vulnerable guy I couldn't take
it I couldn't stand it you know so you
know stuff like oh you're so much
funnier than him why don't you go up you
know talking to their friend you know
and so um so it was rough it was rough
but there would be some some really good
ones interspersed with with the awful
ones but there were many many awful ones
but finding your own sense of humor is
kind of a whole different thing is that
something that maybe comes alive at
summer camp is it that came alive in
college it did yes I had no idea that I
mean I would watch comedians and I loved
him and laughed right but never crossed
your mind couldn't get enough somebody
was a comedian was coming on TV yeah I
would definitely want to watch it but it
didn't cross my mind that I could do it
nor did I even dream that I was funny
yeah I had no idea I was funny nobody
nobody laughs at anything I did nobody
nobody so it's not even in you're not
even in my thoughts that I'm the least
bit funny okay so then in college then I
get then I leave I leave Brooklyn go to
Maryland and I go to Maryland and all of
a sudden I meet some new people so I
make some new friends and I'm suddenly
this funny guy to them or you feel about
freedom to them yes so I'm starting to
say things that they're finding funny
you know are they the realism most of
them were self-deprecating
sure and I had to do with my own
inadequacies particularly with women but
they were real thoughts oh they are real
thought and
and they're laughing yeah and I'm
shocked but I love it yeah sure yeah
it's a ridiculous response yeah it's
time you're getting yeah and so and now
all of a sudden I'm I'm a funny guy
oh like overnight you know yeah
whereas I wasn't before and then it was
there a moment of hey look at this what
is this I don't know I don't know if I
had that moment but but at some point
you cross from receiving to making the
effort yes to get those lines yes yeah
and that's a transition yeah but still
didn't translate it all into become a
comedian
no no yeah just for attention maybe go
just just because I like getting laughs
sure but I never acquainted my sight I
think you have to understand is that I
had a very low opinion of myself
weird did you see that guy didn't think
I never I never ever thought of myself
as being able that I would ever be able
to do anything so creative so to be or
anything oh so - so to go up on a stage
and and and be a comedian might sound a
question that was about what wouldn't
even enter my my thoughts right it was
to go out of this out of the realm of
possibilities but it has to enter your
thoughts at some point at some point it
does yeah because what happened um
was it a dare no we're nowhere near the
possibility right now and there's a
chasm between that place yes and you
being on stage yeah after college do you
know what I wanted to do I had a series
of jobs cabdriver having everything to
do with your major that you graduated
with my major cab driver paralegal
private chauffeur you know stuff like
that and I'm lost I'm a lost soul you
know in New York yes a loss all the
parents beside themselves what are we
gonna do yes at the universe I would
overhear conversations that were
heartbreaking you know terrible about
you
yeah about me yeah oh yeah what are we
gonna do
[Laughter]
they send me to a psychiatrist sure now
and so I take the subway to broke him to
the psychiatrist and you know what what
do you go what it's it you can't do
anything from me no so then I then I
don't know how why I thought of this but
I I decided to take an acting class you
don't know how or why well I guess I
guess maybe I thought I was in plays in
in elementary school huh yeah you had a
little stage time I had a little stage
time in elementary school fantastic so I
did that and what I'm gonna I want to
try that so I thought I'll try that so I
tried that and I didn't really like it
all that much but this one time I had to
speak in front of the class as myself
and there were laughs mm-hmm it was a
prepared text from I so read the scene
but you just had to do something Byers I
had to take a character what a character
with some bull you had to improvise I
had to improvise yeah right and it
allows you to think on your feet
yeah and incorporate your own thoughts
and ideas right right not somebody
else's scream at somebody else's script
just yeah exactly
so that got laughs yeah it did and so
after that got laughs but that's that
was the the moment for me that I thought
okay wait a second stand-up comedy yeah
that's that's what I'm gonna buy what am
I having this crossed my mind before
yeah yeah right I just made a joke in
the board in the teacher yeah this could
be a thing right was there sense like
that that was an actual yeah mentum yes
yeah that's pretty fantastic yeah and
that's a moment and then and then I I
knew somebody who was doing it somebody
from college and I I had coffee with him
and yeah he said well here's what you
have to do you have to write some
material and you could go on here you
could go on here and go on there you
know so he gave me a list of places and
I start okay and then I told everybody I
said I'm gonna do stand-up comedy I have
a notebook filled with ideas I I write
down ideas when I think of them and
sometimes it's like driving a
you can go we hit up hours not hours but
in this case weeks without getting one
but when I was doing the show when I was
into it that was that was like my main
focus coming up with ideas so everything
was an idea didn't matter how bad it was
I was writing everything down that I
could and so I'll get I'll go okay
what's what's it's like a Mission
Impossible team almost what's who's who
what's the idea that I want to use for
this week and I'll get an idea and then
I'll start looking at some of my other
ideas and I'll go oh this one all of a
sudden some of the ideas start to
connect with me and so I pick out my
Mission Impossible team